grant's last battle the story behind the
personal memoirs of ulysses s grant
my name tag here says for signing books
afterwards
pardon my silence i can't speak
i have laryngitis so can you hear me or
not
okay no all right let's let's try the
best we can here
let's be right into it you know i
i don't can you hear me now
can you hear me in the back
okay
well
i'm uh just as well that i'm you listen
closely
because i'm going to tell you some
secrets
at the beginning trade secrets here but
we're all in the business here you're
all in business right i've never spoken
to booksellers before last week and of
course i got laryngitis before my book
tour started
so we'll see what happens
but uh actually being in this house
chamber though it's only the house i
want to ask your advice as booksellers
about the title of my book
of course
whatever you say
it won't change the title
that sounded a little like our president
uh this last week
consulting with congress but i want to
consult with you i've been i've been in
the u.n next week i've been watching him
closely how he operates so
i'll tell you how we came to the title
uh secrets here actually this was the
working title for the book from the time
i first proposed it to viking is there a
viking representative here by the way
good
okay don't let this get beyond this
repair telling behind the scenes here a
little bit that's what i do
um
it was a working title
up through the point when i sent the
manuscript in all finished notes and
everything
a couple of months ago
and my editors said everyone here loves
it
marketing people love it they're very
excited by this book
by the way it has a new title
this was days before i was to go into
the catalog
which was the moment of truth here on
the title
she said it's now called
keeping secrets
i said
she said the marketing people uh really
like that they're very excited by it
i said um
who came up with that
she said the vice president she runs the
corporation again another analogy to our
nation situation here again
so
uh she said no she she liked it
keeping secrets i said but
that's not what i did
i said
i said don't worry about that
it'll sell well
i said well
it's the opposite of what i did
uh did she really read this book
uh
what what what could she possibly have
had in mind
she said well she wanted two words and
one of them had to be a verb
so i i thought about it for a while and
i said i i can't live with this
we've got to find two other words
so she said
okay how about
telling secrets
i said well
that's what i did i wasn't crazy about
it but when i went home and told my wife
and her friends you know why females
reacted this way they said impossible
as as sam goldman used to say in two
words impossible
uh he said uh that's tattletail
telling tales out of school which is
sort of what i do a little
uh telling sounds trivial sounds like
gossip you cannot cannot do that
so uh i came up with uh with the title
unauthorized disclosure
now that may not be too familiar to you
but that's the official term for leaking
i've never really liked the term leaking
my wife
hates hates me to be called a leaker
says it sounds incontinent
so
uh but anyway unauthorized disclosure
has been in the news a lot because
nearly every other day
secretary of defense donald rumsfeld
is talking about unauthorized
disclosures which are ruining our
national security
and which are definitely crimes and for
which people will go to prison when he
prosecutes them which he will do as soon
as he finds out who possibly could have
done this
and they've been there are many many
more unauthorized disclosures
um than there were during the vietnam
war
at this stage
or even later
and i think by the way i disagree with
runsfield i think that's all to the good
for the first talking golf resolution
which was passed the week i went to work
for the pentagon in august of 1964
there were two
senators who voted against it
not 23.
there was a zero house of
representatives
zero voted against that that bill
uh at that time
so this is definitely improvement and
there would not have been 133 members
many republicans and democrats no no
many democrats in the house several
republicans
let me get that straight several
republicans in the house jim leach and
others
one republican in the senate chafee of
rhode island
and many democrats who voted
in the minority
of democrats even
against this bill this time that would
not have happened without the
unauthorized disclosures
that people have honorably been giving
patriotically been giving allowing a
degree of debate far far inadequate
very inadequate but far greater than
happened the week i came to the pentagon
in august of 64.
so there were some votes
actually somebody had picked up the
phone
in the pentagon and called senator morse
before he was to question
secretary of defense mcnamara in
hearings top secret hearings
on august 5th i believe it was
the day after i came
i regret to say and warned him what
questions to ask just raise these
questions i can't tell you anymore
he didn't give him any documents
and with that though morse did raise the
questions
he was not able to do anything about the
flat explicit
top secret lies he got from secretary of
defense mcnamara in answer
i go through this
in the book what the lies were
what i knew
as a lowly i was a high paid i was a
high-level civil servant at that point i
came into the government but i was
working as a high-paid clerk
an assistant to an assistant secretary
of defense
no decision-making role whatever but i
handled a lot of paper and i saw the
paper that was coming over my desk
on august 4th was the day
my first day in the pentagon took 24
hours
i spent all night there
because um
i was watching the raids
our first air attacks
over vietnam
um
which uh started that night
that morning in the talking gulf
in response to what was alleged to be
a an attack uh on our ships
let me come back back to that in a
minute
actually that's the that's the story
that starts this book actually
i didn't know this book would be coming
out
the week
that tonkin gulf 2 was passed
and timely
i'm unhappy
very unhappy for my country that this
book is so timely anyway uh let me
finish up
come back to that how much time do we
have by the way
okay
i don't know if i don't okay i don't
know if my voice is up to that let's see
anyway coming back to the the title
we're working with unauthorized
disclosure which as you can see i'm four
so i liked giving the book unauthorized
disclosures the title i want to stick it
in donald rumsfeld's eye to be to be
truthful
and say here it is there's more of them
here and more coming come and get me
and
we'll see what the prosecution picture
is because he's bluffing to a
considerable degree he doesn't have a
law to go with that would clearly stand
up as constitutional if it went to the
supreme court of course this supreme
court is a little worrisome but
he we don't have an official secret side
congress for the first time
passed an official secrets act for the
first time in our history
three years ago in the last days of
clinton's rule
do any of you booksellers know that that
happened
is there somebody let me see a hand
so you don't know that clinton vetoed
that
which is why we don't have a
congressional
act
importantly at the moment this president
would not veto that when it comes up
again needless to say and that was true
before 9 11.
that'll make a difference uh my book i
think is sort of addressed without
knowing it would come up this year to
the question of why we should not have
an official secret sect why we do not
because of the first amendment
and why
the founders of our country
the drafters of the first amendment
happen to be james madison had it right
at the time and this is not the time
to remove that amendment or get an
official secret set
so anyway i said okay unauthorized
disclosure two words
um she said
sounds like a spy novel
i said well
all right
very good what's wrong with that
so she said no it sounds like something
by tom clancy
i said
hmm well here's a title for you
unauthorized disclosure by tom clancy
uh you don't even have to put my name on
the cover at all
she said the legal department wouldn't
buy it
but anyway we came up with we came back
to the title
secrets
so uh how many here would have preferred
keeping secrets you're the sellers
telling secrets
see one hand for tony
uh secrets
best title
this is not a very responsive you you're
looking like the republicans in china no
in congress here you're supposed to put
your hand up when i
i'm not the president i know
oh
[Music]
how titles are made you know there's an
old story that two things you never want
to see made sausage and legislation and
this is uh my book is about the process
of decision making
okay
so then uh pentagon papers
uh how many of you be frank on this one
then
whether you were booksellers or not
and need to know what the pentagon
papers were or what that was about
how many of you you can't hear me let me
see hands don't be modest on this
because i won't take the time otherwise
what do i need to tell you a little
about what the pentagon papers were you
say no but a few people say
i'll say it very briefly
it was a study that i
[Music]
worked on in the pentagon when i came
back from vietnam
in fact
again
since thank you i got a brief good but
brief introduction i don't know how many
of you know my background which goes in
this how many need a few words on on my
background
okay right if we only had brief time i
wouldn't do it
um he mentioned i was a harvard phd that
was after i got out of the u.s marine
corps which i enlisted in as an officer
candidate during the korean emergency in
54. fighting was mostly over then but
that was because i'd gotten deferred
for two years
to go to cambridge university in england
finish my
ba in one degree
and i felt being a strong cold warrior
already at that time and really
throughout the period of this book which
goes up to
73.
um
very patriotic i was 14 when the war
ended in the second world war
uh grew up on war movies on john wayne
uh john wayne specifically uh and
enlisted recruited me into the marine
corps
with the sands of iwo jima i don't know
how many people are old enough to
remember that one
and that recruited most of the marine
corps and reruns
i met him once when i was in the marines
and bought him a bottle of wine we were
at a restaurant together
and
i went in the marines uh feeling that
i'd been deferred i had a deferment and
it was my turn to go time to go
i extended my tour there for a year
this this is very briefly in the book
this book is not an autobiography it's a
memoir mainly from 64 to 73
but there is a chapter in there about my
background
and one thing that's very relevant right
now is this
i went in the marines as a patriotic
american which i am for sure
in part because i admired and
loved the fact that during second world
war we led the world
against aggression
i understood that the korean attack to
have been aggression
all i knew was which he was actually
and i was very proud that we were i
thought it was a right war a limited war
i was proud of the marine role in that i
mean it wasn't a marine yet but i became
proud of it
we were putting back aggression
and when i was due to get out of the
marines to go to harvard
graduate school
i
read in the papers that there was about
to be war in the middle east
that
[Music]
nasa of egypt of egypt
same general area we're talking about
here was threatening the actually had
just nationalized the suez canal
there was likely to be war i did not
want my battalion in which i was
i'm now very proud still very proud of
the fact that i had been a rifle company
commander
as a first lieutenant i'm very pleased
by that
in fact i uh
i'm a little embarrassed to say the one
other event i've been here i was on a
panel with jim lehrer
i didn't know he was a marine which he
mentioned he was in the marines the same
time i was
and so i saw him afterwards and he
didn't know i'd been a marine so
we'd had a lot to talk about except that
i couldn't talk
and uh
it was the late 50s when he was in but i
asked him what he'd done he said he was
a rifle to two meter
and i say i'm embarrassed because i
could not was just saying
i was a rightful company commander
but the point was i wasn't trying to
trump him it is that was probably the
most satisfying several months of my
life
professional life
not personally
uh
uh so anyway i did not want my company
to be going into battle
without me
if they went in suez so i i canceled my
fellowship three-year fellowship at
harvard
they said i could reapply
and uh
and extended in the marine corps for a
year and i went over and
in the course of that
uh there came a time
when
my ship was ordered this is in the book
briefly
ordered toward the southeast corner of
the mediterranean
and i was given my first top secret
clearance
marines don't see top secrets they
barely see
uh
confidential
usually deal with secret if if anything
and they gave me a top secret clearance
for the top secret war plans of the
sixth fleet i was to make a landing plan
for haifa
and the guy next to me was making a
landing plan for our battalion
for alexandria
we didn't know which plan we would use
it depended on which the president
decided who we were fighting
israel or egypt and uh we assumed that
we had to use my plan against israel
we'd be
wiped out
and if we went against egypt we thought
very chauvinistically well we'll go
through
maybe yes maybe no in the end we
evacuated uh about 1500 civilians from
alexandria while i was being while the
harbor was being bombed by the british
and french i've been bombed by the
british and french
and
i'm not going to make references to the
present right now you can connect the
dots
i'll just tell what's in the book which
is my experience
obvious some relevance to what's
happening right now what we're looking
at
so
i had been you know i've never told this
in public before but since it's in the
book it's so relevant to this week i'll
tell you
at that point i was no longer a company
commander i was an assistant operations
officer so i was assigned to read up on
and brief
our officers
as to
the background of this war that was
about to happen
and so i read the in the book ships
library
uh britannica they had several
encyclopedias there were a couple of
books on the middle east one by elf uh
albert kessler
some arthur kessler i read up quite a
bit and i thought
my god
nasser had every right to nationalize
this canal what the british and france
are doing and we knew it was about to
happen because of our cables you were
getting
is a colonial war again as they're
reinstituting their colony
now at that time
i would have used either plan the
president said or we said
it's a for the president to decide
right who we go to war with
but i was happy
when president eisenhower
who i had not voted for as a democrat
said this is aggression we won't have it
you must stop
you must stop
and actually i met years later
i met years later
the um
man who'd been in charge of the planning
for the british invasion
of the suez canal
and uh at an institute for strategic
studies meeting
i was you know big pentagon
representative
and i asked them in your wildest dreams
had you imagined that you'd get an order
to stop your offensive in the middle of
the canal and go back
because eisenhower had said you must
stop and we will not support the pound
if you go on
they pulled them back in the middle of
the operation anyway
two two memories i have of that that are
very relevant today
one is
wow
eisenhower did it right
i'm proud of my republican president
that he put us
in the position of being against
aggression
even when it's committed
by our closest ally
and that was the greatest rift
in
the british american reliance perhaps
ever
certainly to this day notice it isn't
happening right now
um that was a terrific rift i was proud
of that i said that's what i came into
the marines for
and another reason that i came into the
marines was
i'd grown up during the war
watching movies
of london being bombed by the nazis
i thought of that as pure nazism
the essence of nazism
bombing civilians
bombing which hit civilians whatever it
was aimed at this was aimed at civilians
i didn't know what the british were
doing to the cities of germany i didn't
know what we were doing to the cities of
japan from then on which was exactly the
same as the nazi practice we were
imitating the nazis
in response
to the nuts
burning them down killing as many
civilians as we possibly could
i don't expect us to do that in this war
by the way and we did not do that in
vietnam though it could have happened
the vietnam war could have gotten much
much much worse
for the vietnamese than it ever did
and i think for ourselves
so something was learned about this
direct targeting but at the time
i didn't want to be involved in bombing
civilians so i joined the marine corps
in part i was offered a job in the air
force i didn't i didn't want to be in
the air force
so i i wanted to be with marines who
fought hand-to-hand as in john wayne
there's some truth to that in the
pacific
one a lot of civilians around though
more than i read about actually
on okinawa can you hear me still
can you hear me
i don't hear in the background will you
wave your hands if you can hear me
okay i don't want to be told afterwards
i wish i could have heard you
okay
so i read in the international edition
of time while we were on that mission
in rome the week i met john wayne we
came back
i saw pictures of what we were doing to
put saeed with now we the british and
french
i've never seen them since
we were leveling portside why do i say
we look at that you know nato
i was in the marines
in contrast to the we then when
a little habit you pick up in the
executive branch which i worked for for
about 15 years is you say we or whether
you identify with it it's us we're on
the team
i've got to get out of that
anyway i was glad that americans did not
have to see pictures like that of what
we were doing when we were doing
to the civilians of egypt
at that time
i felt sorry for the british and french
who had to look at pictures like that if
they did
of what was done in the course of their
colonial aggression
okay i came back
and
i'm making this much too long let's see
where we're going how much time really
do we have
okay
um i hadn't meant to go into that but
i think you'll see
again i don't have to connect the dots
here
how that applies to what's coming up
we're not going to target civilians this
time
that we probably will
as in
um
the gulf war 11 years ago
as in serbia use precision guided
weapons
to hit waterworks
infrastructure
sewage plants and electricity
now those are forbidden targets by the
hague convention just like housing
the effect of that
i read
and these are the points that senator
byrd and other heroes were making last
week in arguing against this
the effect of that has been according to
the un
to kill hundreds of thousands of
children in the decades after the war
the decade
after the gulf war
i haven't read what's happening in
serbia but i don't i'd be interesting to
know when we knocked out their health
structure their infrastructure
that's what's lying ahead that's why
there's a very serious target anyway
the upshot was that i
came back from vietnam rather from the
marines went to harvard wrote a thesis
on
uh later
on uncertainty
decision making under uncertainty
gambling decisions
how people make them why they make them
that's been my professional specialty
actually
that's another lecture i'm giving in in
november on the keynote lecture at the
society for the for judgment and
decision theory
decision making very abstract
that'll be in november
i'm not going to talk very abstractly
that's what my i did write a book on
that uh last year
i wrote the book 39 years ago it was
published last year
it was my thesis
uh you can get it on amazon
on the amazon list of bestsellers and
you know where they rank all the books
it lists it ranks i believe one million
three hundred thousand
it's going up and you know it's hung
pretty steady there i think that garland
overpriced it at 65
but anyway that's pretty abstract but i
won't be talking about abstraction a
month from now
when i believe we'll be bombing
but that's just my own bed
i don't think they'll wait that long
um
even if we aren't bombing yet i'll say
we're looking at a gamble now
the headlines are that many people are
making unauthorized disclosures
that they do not agree inside the
government with the estimates the
president has been presenting as flat
assertions
that saddam would use a nuclear weapon
or
if he got it and when he got it without
having been attacked
and second this is now an authorized
disclosure authorized by george tenet
head of the cia
but let me just make a little bet to you
this letter from tenet
to the congress
was not authorized by the president of
the united states and i'll bet that in
the white house they are furious
attendance near
insubordination to the white house
by giving his actual best unclassified
advice he declassified it
to the congress and what he said was
that saddam
is
we think very unlikely to give these
weapons to terrorists
if he gets them
biological chemical or nuclear
or
to use them against us
if he is not being attacked
but on the other hand
if he is attacked it is our judgment
that he has a very high likelihood of
using them
against our troops
against israel tenets said that
what will israel's response be to that
they said they would use nuclear weapons
they don't say nuclear because they have
never to this day admitted use the word
nuclear
directly they said they will use
everything they have and they have
nuclears
the man who revealed that guy named
mordechai venuno
has been in prison for revealing it to
the london times for 16 years 13 years
in total solitary
for revealing to the israelis
what everybody else in the world knew
but the israelis weren't sure
because their officials refused to
confirm it
so by the way i i rambling here a little
bit i'll give you an interesting one
when i studied nuclear crises
in the pentagon that was one of my jobs
later in the pentagon i've skipped over
a lot here
i actually discovered
that essentially everybody in the world
know that
israel that i looked up suez when i had
the chance to because i'd been in it
so in a
a room like a safe
a windowless safe room
in the state department where i was
authorized to do this research which
held the eyes only
eyes only
literally eyes only for the president
files of letters between kennedy and
khrushchev and eisenhower and bulgan and
stuff like that
i discovered that we had known very well
and but by this time everybody in the
world knows except the
british that when i was on that ship in
the mediterranean
ben gurion
of israel
[Music]
the french
foreign minister whose name escapes me
at the moment and anthony eden
and anthony eden met in a chateau in
france and planned the entire invasion
the conspiracy invasion which they were
trying to keep from eisenhower because
they knew he wouldn't like it
now by this time everybody knows that
except the british
to this day
and the reason that is
is because anthony eden simply flatly
denied it in his memoirs
so they don't know it they're like us
they're like everybody
it's hard to believe
that your leaders flatly lie to you
not hard to believe that they mislead a
little that they don't tell you the
whole truth
uh that they uh you know they fudge and
they frame it and spin it and so forth
which they do all that in fact that's
mostly what they do
they also lie a great deal
all the time not just the president not
just republicans or democrats presidents
and not just our leaders
not just democratic leaders
as i.f stone said he summed it all up in
a way one of the major messages of this
book
he summed up and i'd heard him say this
but i didn't believe it till i've been
through it
all government officials lie
and nothing they say
is to be believed
now it doesn't mean that they everything
they say is a lie
they tell as much truth as will serve
their purposes as much as they can
afford to it means that anything they
say
may be
a lie
as well as for example
i'll give you one right now
cheney says vice president is a very
smart guy
says is saying day by day he believes
that our invasion of iraq will lead to a
democratic
iraq and a democratic middle east
having after we have been welcomed as
liberators
by
uh the people of iraq roses us and so
forth he paints this in very concrete
terms
and um
i just read this in time this week
and that um
the iraqi army he feels confident
will fall apart
all of it
as soon as we go in
then it will liberators we're liberators
then there will be a macarthur period
sort of as in japan and then a
democratic open society which in turn
will spread to the new middle the rest
of the middle east
okay now that's what he says now
that is his justification and the
president's
for launching what everyone can see is a
preventive war by the way preemptive is
another
misleading title
close to a lie it's a misuse of the term
uh i did war planning
our planning is based on preemption of a
nuclear attack but that means if they
are on the way if their missiles have
launched if we know from electronic
intelligence or infrared or whatever
that they are about to launch or are on
the way our infrared satellites get that
we don't wait for the warheads to arrive
you may believe and you may have been
told certain many times that we wait and
take the second blow and we'll never go
over there and do it first but that's
not that's not our planning
we will all our plans are based on on
going first going second first as they
say on preempting that attack that's
what preempting means it's a technical
term
what he's talking about which he's using
the word preemptive for has nothing to
do with preemption
no attack is on the way nothing is
imminent
it's a war that is not
in the context of an imminent
or ongoing attack it's a preventive war
and that's the best term you can put for
it
another term is what the british and
french were doing in suez aggression
that's what eisenhower called it then
and he was right
it's what the whole world called what
saddam did 11 years ago
he said he was liberating a real
province of
iraq and so forth i don't know if any of
his people believed that but his
soldiers didn't want to hear to fight
for that
but it was aggression
and on the basis of that word i'm giving
a talk about iraq i'll try to stop now
it's not in the book obviously
but i can tie it up with the book
quickly
on the uh the basis of that not just a
word but the reality
that saddam was violating the central
principle of international order for the
last several hundred years the one thing
everybody agrees on
what is aggression very hard to get
agreement on that usually but once in a
while
you don't you get consensus that's
aggression
um
so when saddam did that
all his allies just about supported us
we used their bases they chimed in they
did everything and they weren't all that
great friends of us uh either
at that point but aggression that has to
be stopped
well they ain't gonna do that to us
we're the united states
they're not gonna
accept
but
uh the fact is
a lot of people in the
in the government right now
i can feel confident from my experience
you know i jumped around here
i was saying a moment ago that cheney
was saying things
i read them last night and i wrote in
the margin
can richard cheney possibly believe this
you know the roses at us the uh the
democracy there ain't going to be any
democracy we will not allow democracy in
the middle east but that's in in iraq in
part because it would split up iraq and
we don't want that
uh we've supported a sunni
uh
dictatorship
sunni muslim
forever essentially
which is a minority about fourteen
percent of the iranian of the iraqis are
sunni
sixty-four percent are
shiite like iran
what's the chance we're going to allow
one man one woman one vote
to the shiites
in iraq to join iran
there's really no chance
so democracy is not in their future
okay there's no more chance than we were
about to allow as i realized when that
when i read the pentagon papers
what i learned
having by this time i didn't even
mention this but been to vietnam
for two years
witnessed combat
as a civilian
participated i was shot at i even shot
back
because i was a former marine company
commander so i used that background
which was described at length now in the
book
in vietnam
i used that to observe places where
people who didn't have that background
couldn't observe
i saw things that civilians didn't
ordinarily see
[Music]
on a lighter note cheney didn't see them
he was draft age during vietnam but he
spent the war in a secure location
in uh in wyoming
in wyoming he missed his chance
unlike powell the one man in the
administration who did see vietnam and
who by all accounts
is
digging his heels in against this war
like every military man we've heard from
every military man
all the ones who worked for bush senior
for clinton for reagan
everyone
only civilians we've heard of who were
not in vietnam though they were all
draft age
are pushing this war and saying it's
going to be a cakewalk which norman
schwarzkopf says it is not going to be a
cakewalk
okay
what's i wish this book actually it's
they say it's timely actually it's a
good month or two overdue
i wish i'm still timely it's going to be
timely for quite a while
our conflicts in the middle east are not
going to be over in two weeks
or three weeks
even if saddam is found and assassinated
etc
as i say saddam is no more
representative himself than a shiite in
its way
of iraq
no more representative than the man we
made dictator of vietnam
for many years siem
who is a catholic
uh
i never
noticed
in vietnam
the funny thing about that country of
buddhists
entirely
being run by a catholic
or what that said about our relation
to vietnam i really never thought of
that until i read the history in the
pentagon papers
it might have been more obvious if he'd
been jewish for example
they might have seen more they didn't
vote this man in somehow
it was a little worse than being jewish
because the catholics were the ones who
had collaborated with the french they've
been converted by the french and they've
been given high jobs by the french
so forth so a catholic president was not
illogical by the way our president hugh
the general too was also a catholic he
converted
saw the light
so um
our our our man in iraq
is not going to be broadly represented
he ain't going to be occurred let me
tell you that for example
so um
i read in the pentagon papers in 69 by
which time i had already been thinking
we should get out of vietnam
for reasons that are in the book but
i've used up my time here so i won't go
we should get out of vietnam
what i read was something that i think
some people in the pentagon probably
perceive today about this situation
because it's different this is much more
open aggression
than vietnam ever was
after i studied history that's in the
pentagon papers
what i didn't know in the pentagon was
we'd been backing a colonial war there
from the beginning
that it was not a legitimate worthwhile
altruistic cause that went wrong as i
believed
back in colonial war paying 80 of the
cost of it for nine years that's what i
read this is the war i'd been shot at in
and that i shot back although i'm glad
to say i'm not aware of having hit
anybody that's not a joke i just didn't
have any target standard
that war
had been wrong from the start
we had no more right to win in vietnam i
conclude and if that puts you off you
know read the book and see if it still
puts you up
i'd like this to be read by a lot of
people who still support that war i hope
it will be
and i know it has been to some degree by
some military people i know i'd like it
to be read by a lot of vietnam veterans
who want to understand how this could
have happened
how could they have done it
that's what people will be asking i
believe however this comes out in the
next little while in iraq how could they
have done it well this book isn't about
they this book is about we
about my colleagues and me
how could i have done it i can see i
didn't know the history but then
how do i explain that i didn't look it
up
i didn't know about well i was 30 years
old at the start when i first went to
vietnam
just out of the marines and so forth
but um
how could uh how could this have
happened
well
at any rate what i read was that there
was we had no right to win in vietnam
from the beginning
any more than we had anymore hope any
more than the french
and no more prospect of winning
than the french that's very different in
iraq itself
we'll win iraq that's a different kind
of war will we win the resistance that
may follow it how will pacification look
in vietnam after we have baghdad whether
we did it surgically or we did it
brutally as in port saeed and level it
one way or another we'll have baghdad
saddam will not be ruling a year from
now
will the fighting be over in iraq will
it be over elsewhere will it be over in
afghanistan later on
we don't know
i don't know you don't know and the
president doesn't know
there's no way to know
that's the gamble that congress just
signed on to
very irresponsibly except for
133
bold courageous patriarchy
led by barbara lee of a year ago
and some republicans and 23
senators 21 republicans 21 democrats one
republican one independent jeffords
still looking very good jeffords by the
way
senator byrd looking very good
bird
said in his speech
he is one of two people in the senate
who were present
to vote on the first tonkin golf
resolution when i was in the pentagon
he said i am ashamed of that decision
i regret it intensely
i
wish that i had been the third person
along with morrison gruening
to vote against it
ted kennedy younger at the time
also voted against this of course
at this point very much to their credit
my problem then was
what do i do when i perceive from this
history what is not easy to perceive in
that case
this is an aggressive war it's a
wrongful war
how far should i go
well i won't recapitulate the book i
will say that i had the luck to meet at
that time
americans young americans who were doing
everything they could
and that meant since these were some of
them were male
and draft age
like all the others
running the government now
that they would refuse to go do it
openly
make a statement of their resistance to
what they thought was a wrongful war do
it non-violently
and truthfully
like gandhi like martin luther king
like thoreau
spent the night in jail protesting what
he called and what u.s grant agreed with
and what lincoln agreed with
was an american war of aggression
against mexico and that's why thoros
spent his night in jail
the rose said at that time in his essay
on civil disobedience
cast your whole vote
not a strip of paper merely
but your whole influence
well
a lot of people in congress last week
cast their vote wrong
some of them cast it right
on their conscience
when they tell you why they voted yes
should you believe that any more than
executive officials
do congressmen tell you the truth about
why they do things more than executives
no no no no no no
how do you know then
well you make a judgment
when bird say you know off all the
circumstances
i believe byrd is telling the truth when
he gives his reasons for voting no
maybe there's other reasons as well
but as far as he goes let's go for the
others as well barbara lee etc
the ones who said yes
hard to believe that they believed some
of this stuff
any more than cheney
but who am i pointing at
including this book of how i did not
leave the government i did not tell what
i knew
at the time when i could have
senator morris told me in 1971 after the
pentagon papers came out
this 7 000 page top secret history
quote of u.s decision making in vietnam
from 1945 to 1968 that's the title of
the pentagon paper
seven thousand pages all top secret
i copied it at the rand corporation in
1969 after at a time when i believe
nixon was about to escalate again
this this is the heart of the book
and i gave it to senator fulbright the
former relations committee
he promised hearings or he said he he
hoped to hold hearings so that he did
not two invasions later i gave it to the
new york times to the washington they
were enjoined
then to the washington post they were
enjoined
then two in the end seventeen other
newspapers
four were enjoined altogether
subject of a big manhunt while i was
putting this out that's following the
book
um supreme court voided the injunctions
but i was put on trial eventually facing
115 years in prison
[Music]
as the book tells
that didn't seem to have had any good
effect the war went on
but for reasons we which i had time to
go into what not amazingly enough
it turned out that there was an effect
because nixon was so
afraid
that i might have other revelations
about him and i did but i didn't have
documents
that he had to take criminal measures to
shut me up
the point is that having read thoreau
and martin luther king and read about
rosa parks and then meeting people
who were living that life on their way
to prison
is what made me realize i should do what
i can
this is only history
but it's all i've got i'll put that out
i wish i had documents on what's now
happening if i'd had i wouldn't have put
out depending on papers i would have put
those out the way some people are very
credibly doing now putting out
information and even documents
on current
planning to show us that this isn't just
about iraq it's the whole middle east
this is not just a d-up raid this is a
thing that's going to eventually involve
scores of thousands of people and so
forth all the stuff that rumsfeld is
complaining about
they are putting it out i'm very happy
that's the major impact i would want
this book to have
would be on people to say
consider in the government if you
believe your president is now lying
the country
into what you see as a wrongful war
that will cost many lives on both sides
then you should consider doing
what i wish i had done
in 1964
1965 don't do what i did
as in this book
don't wait till the bombs are falling
don't wait till it's one war after
another syria iraq iran saudi arabia
put it out now
and whatever cost
to yourself
could it be worth
going to jail for 10 years 100 years 115
years
well
of course
if you're uh if you're able to
contemplate that i don't tell anybody to
do that they have families they have
jobs they have their own calculation
their own sense of what will help and
what they could do otherwise
paul hasn't quit
and i think i know why for the same
reason mcnamara didn't in 66 he believes
i this is my own guess
he believes that if he left
it would go worse
and he could well be right so he has a
very hard choice to make
but people who who don't have to tell
themselves my god maybe i can really
make a difference
inside should be thinking of what they
can do outside
and
i'm trying to say that some people are
doing it
so
we have finally i'll end up with the
fact with
a couple two quotes here
the reason they went after me
is
h.r holdem and this is on tape now
these are unauthorized disclosures that
the president president taped everybody
as you know
tapes got out his didn't plan on that
so just the day after the pentagon
papers came out
h.r holdeman was saying to the president
in the white in the oval office now on
tape a lot of this stuff has never come
out this particular one came out in
april of this last year was that almost
30 years later
31 years later
about the pentagon papers
as don was saying this morning to the
ordinary guy
all this is a bunch of gobbledygook
but out of the gobbledygook comes a very
clear thing
you can't trust the government
you can't believe what they say
and you can't rely on their judgment
and the implicit infallibility of
presidents which has been an accepted
thing in america
is badly hurt by this because it shows
that people do things the president
wants to do
even though it's wrong
and the president can be wrong
that was the message i wanted to get out
the don he was quoting
was donald rumsfeld
who was working for nixon at that time
as a white house aide
and he got the picture he got the
message
and it's true
but telling the truth
can have an effect
my book ends
with this
last page last thing it ends when my
trial ended
congress because of the revelations of
the criminal actions the president had
done
to stop me from telling more
truth
to stop me because i was doing what
scott ritter has been doing for several
months
i was doing everything i could that's
what scott ritter is doing and he's my
latest hero i just sent this book to him
if you know who i mean you know who's
scott ritter
he's doing everything he can
and senator byrd
cast his whole vote
and barbara lee and some others and
that's what's needed
can that do any good well it didn't stop
the resolution and frankly it's not
going to stop this war and this war will
not be averted
i think by anything but it won't be
stopped as a series of wars
without a lot more courage
and sacrifice than we've seen so far
from most of the democrats
or others
but can it help
well it came out the president had um
done a lot of crimes
by because i was on trial they finally
came out in my courtroom
um in congress under the pressure of
that
for the first time the week my trial
ended
states before voted to cut off money
for the war
which
then went through a little process but
it ended in august this was may 11th the
day my trial ended this is the end of
the book here's our oval office tape
which i read after they was released
this april
president's saying to holdeman
the same time at 11 o'clock that judge
byrne in my courtroom was dismissing all
charges against me and tony rousseau on
the grounds of governmental misconduct
which was very nice actually mitchell
was indicted my my attorney general then
was indicted the same morning
and
so that was fine but the more important
thing was
congress had voted
for the first time to cut off the money
so the president now says to haldeman
for example
on this i've heard this i can't imitate
too well with my voice now
for example on this national security
thing
we have the rocky situation where the
son of a bitching thief is made a
national hero and it's going to get off
on a mistrial
and the new york times gets a pulitzer
prize for stealing documents
they're trying to get at us with thieves
what in the name of god have we come to
some satisfaction reading that and the
the end of the book is
what we had come back to
was a democratic republic
not an elected monarchy
a government under law with congress the
courts and the press functioning to
curtail executive abuses as our
constitution envisioned
and as senator byrd laid out for us now
moreover for the first time in this or
any other country
the legislature
was casting its whole vote against an
ongoing presidential war
it was reclaiming through its power of
the purse
the war power it had fecklessly
delegated
nine years earlier
congress was stopping the bombing and
the war was going to end
[Applause]
history bookshelf features the country's
best known american history writers of
the past decade talking about their
books you can watch our weekly series
every saturday at 4